[Music]
okay
when you were on that show that you were
on
the dancing competition i'm blanking
right now america's the best
do you guys do you guys win like an
actual like trophy award like a like a
tangible
award there's like a golden b-boy trophy
oh is that what you didn't win
that's the one i see the whole time
the whole time steve was just thinking
about it he was am i a good listener or
what that was two videos ago that you
were
yeah he was probably waiting for it
because everyone knew but him and he's
all like i thought you're gonna tell me
off camera
oh yeah yeah okay i got it now thank you
for catching me up you're welcome
i'm sorry for your loss it's it's okay i
was
sorry yeah now i've embraced it okay
um salty yeah it was a
golden
but yeah so what do you like yeah it's a
little golden bboy trophy and then uh is
that small
no it's like maybe like this big um and
then like at the
thing at the waist because it's like a
people on a freeze at the waist
it's like not connected it's almost got
like a bubble head kind of like spring
thing so
it's actually really weird so it moves
yeah it's like a dildo
there's that trophy and then i don't
know for nbc what people win
other than like you weren't even close
not even that trophy is one like if you
guys would have won it right does that
mean
every guy in your crew gets to have a
single trophy
so they fight over it whose house it
goes in true like
usually it goes out like the studios the
dance studios is there a place at your
studio where it's like
what could have been and it's just empty
empty shelf you have an empty shop
with the lights just shining right there
and there's like oh
that was really good that's a great burn
i'm sorry
so do you guys have an empty shelf like
burning people
know me i was really really really sorry
no i'm starting to see that visual with
the lights and then there's like cobwebs
it's like it's like a circle where the
trophy should be and
dust around that's right yeah and it's
like
a picture of my parents that were once
happy but like they ripped me out
they're disappointed and there's a
recording this is at the kenja's
museum when you go into the hole this is
our outfit
from that american bass dance crew he
goes this is the trophy that we should
have win
and you can push the button and it's
like we are so disappointed you are not
my son
oh it's the audio clip yeah damn you
gotta push a button for disappointment
yeah
like so every time it's just like a
sorrowful moment of life you go there
and just
hear disappointment from my father
people could live through what you did
then you go you guys want to learn some
dance
this is the deepest ride that this story
has ever done
i'm liking this so far you get to enjoy
this the most because you're so brand
new to this
this whole this yeah this will never
stop
you don't let it end hey i forgot about
it you brought it back
up he actually brought it up like two
videos ago you guys on his own
and because bart's not here we have to
do the honors now
no he had to do the honor yeah you
listen admit it you miss it
can we move on all right let's move on
so wait why did you bring this article
up to
to give him pain no no it makes sense
three minutes in it just it makes sense
but i i it's like there's no [ __ ]
article
no what i wanted to ask you though is um
so
for you was it more about the actual
trophy of winning it or is it like the
title
what did you miss out on what was it
that you were competing for
um cliche serious answer
uh personal glory right to like know
what you're capable of
yeah you know i feel like that shit's
rigged though you can't trust that [ __ ]
it's rigged it is totally
it's a tv show yeah it's a tv show does
it mean who's the best
it's not the america's best it's the
studio's best dance crew
well the reason why i bring it up is not
to to do this to you but please
it does have to do with the article so i
have an article here about
russia this russian teacher of the year
awards wow ceremony and this one video
surfaced and it actually went really
viral because
in this video all the teachers going up
to the stage
touched the award for good luck
but you let me know what you think of
this award okay
it's like a boob or something like a
ceremony a dick shape it has to be dick
shame
oh my god oh why does that look like a
dildo
why does it look like a dill though and
the way they're all
are they all women too you're caressing
it like a dick
it's really nice look at how happy that
lady is holding the dick
yes this is very big isn't it the guy
touched the wings
yes this is very big this is like a
porno
yes that dick sees more action than any
celebrity in america
yeah right look at her face
she's so jealous she's like my husband's
not that big
yeah so that's that was a very
interesting award right what would you
say it is though
a dick a swan a swan but they probably
make it look like a dick on purpose yeah
what is that
that has so little to do with my history
i don't even know what that
it's a trophy isn't it that's something
you do it's an award ceremony
what do you want from me if anthony
didn't bring up his story two videos ago
how would you wouldn't have even thought
of that
i honestly would not have even thought
of it i blame you
i blame you yeah because i was just like
how would tiff have introduced you said
bart if bart was here he would have said
we didn't because we didn't win that's
what you said
hey look guys you own it yeah and trust
me
the whole point is that i don't own the
trophy so
very nice burn very nice but yeah so
uh okay so then there was this poll that
asked
viewers to answer what did the
participants of the teacher
of the year uh touch so
out of more than 400 responses only 25
actually thought that it was the correct
answer
which was a glass pelican yeah [ __ ]
right what can it look like dude they
have huge a huge head we must have seen
that at a weird angle yeah was there no
beak to that thing
yeah cause it's like they forgot to make
the beat because it was just pelican
looking backwards and [ __ ]
it must have been completely behind that
it was like perfectly folded downwards
too
along its neck so it looks like it did
yeah there we go let me see i'll show
you guys a pelican there's a lot of
things
in this world that look like a dick yeah
so here like everything
true or [ __ ] it was it was the beak all
the way down to its
why it's this thing almost
it looks like a dick why is it a pelican
trophy
for a teacher award like wouldn't it be
like a apple or something
are there a lot of pelicans in russia no
yes
no the person who made that definitely
definitely made it very phallic-like
they were horny yeah definitely like
there's not even a separation of the
beak to the neck
or some and i see a little bit but it
looks like like dick striations
why would you not yeah why would you
give a [ __ ] give it a [ __ ]
mushroom head
maybe it was afraid maybe they were
afraid uh it would poke somebody's eye
out if it was a beak
and then they separated it like this
yeah yeah they're like oh that's
dangerous
i think it's yeah probably huh because
she's looking at it
the beak is right here hey honestly
wait look at the lady holding it she's
so happy
their their emotions are giving me so
much life right now that is like the
funniest thing i like how she's wearing
pajamas too
yeah she's just like how come she gets a
little bit [ __ ] the whole time
she's jealous [ __ ] these teachers they
don't deserve to touch the
look of jealousy yes whether it's like
my husband's dick isn't that big
or why does she get to touch it why did
she get the she was like second best
teacher is that why
that's why she's standing closest i did
so much more work than everybody here
i cannot that that looks so you're
saying 300 people said it was
25 out of 400 responses actually thought
that it was a blast
yeah i just need to explicitly
understand what the other like 200
something hey that's eagle-eyed [ __ ]
there
25 or like that's a pelican uh
well 28 300 people then 28
went with a glass crane similar
and then 47 percent thought it was uh
something else
dildo they just wrote uh something else
oh they're just
penis oh no it's a penis right let's
focus on the
proper science here a dildo or a penis
i think it's so funny when things are
dick shaped i love it i don't care
like that that hole right there because
it even it's completely true
yeah i wish the people could see it no
they will we'll take a picture the
editor could put it in post
there you go i'll take a picture right
now it's a it's a really
very powerful dick kind of whole picture
it's like uh austin powers was it
when they put that rocket oh yeah
and then they did all the johnson yeah
yeah that's a
huge winner anyone want a wiener
the first one is brilliant yes it's
awesome yeah what was the second one
oh the second the spike was shagged me
that's my favorite movie
well heather graham was hot heather
graham was high hottest beyonce
is pretty funny that was she's
she's a gold member but she was like
reading the whole time
she was hot though she was very hot i'm
not i'm not saying acting skills
yeah she's perfection i don't even
remember it it just reminds me of one
movie
no because the first one is this one
movie the first one was what's her name
who's still hot as [ __ ]
uh i can't remember oh yeah what's your
denise richards no
damn it who's the first one what about
fat bastard when did fat bastard come in
my baby back baby back oh no second gold
member second movie no he was in spy who
shagged me the reason why i know this
movie so well is because i had the vhs
and i watch it like 10 times a day
vhs is a old-school black kind of
box tape thing that guys has spoolie
things right here
so you have to be kind of rewind that's
what you had to do
last year no a couple years ago we did a
spartan race remember that
and then the place that we stayed at had
a ton of vhs's and we could watch
them on a vhs player that sounds like
the start of a horror movie
yes they had a movie the whole cabin
felt like it was stuck in the 90s it was
so sick when's the last time you saw
something on vhs
got him leviosa i don't know if we even
played a video
but that was the last time i watched the
usual suspects and i could barely
[ __ ] tell what was going on i love
that movie
i haven't seen that one but it's so
weird when you're watching vhs now
because it's everything's so clear now
with
with all our like fuzzy it's all fuzzy
[ __ ] up weird you know i feel like
that's gonna
probably maybe somehow come back just
like with vinyls because
when you play vinyl on a record player
it is not
crisp crisp sounding it has like that
deliberate
warm and fuzzy yeah it's a filter
basically like
movies being filmed on film is like a
completely different look so i feel like
vhs is gonna
maybe one day come back polaroids can
come back maybe vhs
will come back did they ever leave
though but you guys gotta wait i don't
think to rewind and [ __ ]
oh man it's so bad i mean you could get
those super fast
no no it'll still be digital with like a
vhs filter
like why would anybody actually go to
vhs and all the filters that you have on
instagram and whatever
they have that vhs and you gotta watch
it on a [ __ ] tube
you can't watch it on like a flat screen
oh yeah you need the fat
yeah the fat screen the fat screen
in standard definition it's because this
video has been modified to fit your tv
screen
and i think like polaroids they were in
and then they went away as soon as we
had like the point-and-shoot
digital camera and then they came back
so i feel like they've always been
around but like they weren't popular
it's because photo printers are a pain
in the dick to use bro pain in the dick
wow like you try sticking and digging it
that's why
i tried to [ __ ] it it's urethra pain oh
yeah inside the
dick hole yeah within the penis try
sticking it inside his penis
pain no woman would understand so please
stay out of this conversation thank you
i'm not saying i understand it well
putting a photo printer in a urethra
yeah i don't understand that okay well
nobody understands it so
perfect i don't know what it's like
[Music]
you